hi it's me Michelle from lab Martin
again with more science-based Beauty
advice today I'm going to be talking
about purging sometimes when you try a
new skincare product your skin will
break out because the products working
and it has to get worse before it gets
better
that's called purging but other times
the new product makes your skin break
out and it never gets better that's just
a plain old breakup should you keep
going with the product or should you
ditch it here's how to tell the
difference
a purge happens when a skincare product
causes pimple formation to speed up a
pimple starts off as a quilt pore in the
skin called a micro coma turn if your
skin is inflamed enough it can come to
the surface and turn into a pimple it
can also go away on its own without ever
becoming visible products that increase
skin turnover can cause purging these
products speed up how quickly your skin
renews itself so the whole pimple cycle
speeds up any baby pimples already in
your skin will grow up faster and you'll
see a sudden breakout
however products that increase skin
turnover also help prevent new pimples
from forming so once this part is over
your skin settles down and looks clearer
than before if your skin is purging that
means the product is working like it's
meant to on the other hand what could be
happening is a simple break out when
you're sensitive to something in the
product and if you keep using the
product your skin just gets worse it
could be blocking your pores or you
might be allergic or it might just be
too irritating there's a small chance
that your skin will get used to the
product after a while but mostly you'll
just damage your skin more if you keep
using it
it's hard to see for sure whether you're
purging or breaking out but you can
narrow it down a bit by considering
these things keep in mind that none of
these are absolute rules first
what sort of product is it if it
increases skin turnover
it could cause purging here are some
common ones vitamin A products
containing ingredients like rational
vitamin C products benzoyl peroxide
chemical exfoliants like hydroxy acids
eva's difficult Valiants like scrubs and
brushes can cause purging if your skin
isn't used to them most other products
like moisturizers cleansers and
sunscreens won't cause purging secondly
where are the brake helps if you're
purging it should mostly be pre-existing
pimples coming up faster so if you're
breaking out in places where you don't
normally get pimples it probably isn't
purging keep in mind that if the product
is irritating then your acne could be
worse than normal in the same areas
whether you're purging or not for
example Quandt Falls can be replaced
with full-blown pimples this can happen
with purging as well as non purging
breakouts finally how long have you been
purging purging should only last for
about a month the time needed for your
skin to completely renew itself if your
skin isn't getting better after around
six to eight weeks ditch the product
if you're about to start a new product
that could cause purging such as an
exfoliant here are a few tips to make
the process less painful
make sure you introduce the product
slowly this will help minimize
inflammation and slowly speed up your
skin renewal process for example you can
start at a lower concentration of the
active ingredient or dilute the product
by mixing it with moisturizer at first
you can also use it less frequently at
the beginning
be gentle to your skin to reduce
irritation and speed up recovery keep
your skin hydrated with moisturizers use
a gentle cleanser and use anti Aryan and
anti inflammatory products make sure you
keep your skin protected from the Sun
you can treat your poaching breakouts
just like any other breakouts I spot
treat with benzoyl peroxide and tea tree
oil and save the scars with vitamin C
and hydroxy acid exfoliant and that's
the lowdown on purging I hope you found
this useful if you did please comment
and let me know and if you have any
suggestions for future videos please let
me know as well if you'd like to see
more please subscribe to my channel
[Music]